so let me show you this uh video because
i think this is the best way to
explain it um if you don't know who
andrew shearer is uh it's this dude over
here he was the uh he was the guy that
was running up against
um justin trudeau in the last election
he was a leader of the conservative
party failed miserably um
he's just this
i mean he's a nice guy dork you know is
what he really is and
you know um he put this this this video
out here i think it's a prop he's
probably the right guy to do this
because because he's such a kind
friendly sort of face and he's got a
good way of projecting stuff
there's there's a reason why i'm never
going into politics people have often
asked me rich why don't you run for
prime minister why don't you fix things
blah blah and all this thing first of
all one i wasn't born here so i can't
and two
i'm not dishonest like i'm not a pos so
i can't i can't get into politics it's
just not in me like i'm just honest it's
just
i call it like i see it and people don't
like that they want to be lied to is
basically what um you know people that
vote
is what it boils down to is they want to
feel warm and fuzzy about [ __ ] that
they really can't deliver on so this is
you know this is like the code in the
matrix guys this is unplugging from the
lies this is you know this is certainly
aligned with the stuff that i talk about
so let's play this video real quick and
i'm gonna offer some commentary on what
exactly is going on and and how this is
gonna affect people in canada did you
have to ask anybody's permission to
watch this video of course not that
would be ridiculous but the liberals
have a piece of legislation that is
going to give the government a lot of
control over what you can see and post
online i want to talk to you about free
speech today
censorship it's everywhere whether it's
russia today all canadians or me
censorship is back in fashion this is
bill c-11 this piece of legislation will
expand the powers of something called
the crtc now what's the crtc you might
not have ever heard about it well if
you've ever wondered why you can't get
certain television stations or watch
certain shows on canadian cable packages
it's because in ottawa there is a group
of people and they make decisions on
what is safe
for canadians to watch and the liberals
want to expand that into the internet
imagine that there's a government agency
in ottawa that makes decisions for you
to protect you from watching things that
might make you uncanadian all of a
sudden it took the children 40 minutes
to locate canada on the map marge anyone
can miss canada all tucked away down
there under this bill they will be able
to make new regulations regulations
don't have to pass through parliament
with the stroke of a pen the crtc can
make new rules about what you can post
and what you can see online they're even
going so far to start to regulate what
users who make revenue off of their
youtube channels have to comply with it
is simply impossible to regulate a
platform like youtube without also
regulating creator content it's like
promising not to regulate books while
regulating what can be sold in
bookstores
so
i don't know who that guy is but i sat
in a chair like that
in parliament in
the province of ontario at queen's park
for a bill that they were introducing in
2012 i know exactly what that guy's
doing i've been there i've done i'm
going to talk more about it at the end
of the video but let's just carry on
just so you understand this again this
has got half a million views right like
this is picking up steam will undermine
your ability to create content and have
other people see it it's going to affect
what
videos come up in your youtube stream
it's going to affect what people are
allowed to post on social media sites
all in the name of protecting you but
hold on let's go back a second
this isn't just about bill c-11 or the
crtc this is about free speech freedom
of speech used to be a unifying
principle that both the left and the
right would agree on but as the radical
left gets increasingly angry and
intolerant they're no longer interested
in promoting their ideas or debating
yours
they just try to stifle anyone who
disagrees with them
so just to add to that people don't want
to hear your opinion anymore
they want to hear their opinion coming
out of your mouth i'm going to say that
again
these these people that are trying to
control the narrative information ideas
anything that might contradict their
narrative information or ideas they do
not want to hear your opinion they want
to hear their opinion coming out of your
mouth and this is what they're this is
what they're doing again
youtube is like hitting this from the
angle of well if you're a canadian
youtuber you're not going to get reach
anymore and you're not going to get ad
revenue
again i'll talk about all this and how
it's going to impact me potentially in
the future but
but but this guise of like you know
canadian
content
that's not the reason behind it there's
always a story behind the story right
and like those that have unplugged
understand that component those that are
still plugged in they're just like
sleepwalking through life oh okay
whatever he says boss i'll just you know
i'll vote for that
spurred on by the views of psychology
professor jordan peterson
they drowned out his talk
at mcmaster university in march
and that's a hallmark of big government
isn't it a telltale sign that a
government is getting too big and too
intrusive into our lives is always that
it attacks free speech when you go back
and look at authoritarian regimes
they always start with attacking freedom
of expression and it's always done in
the name of protecting you you go back
to the french revolution where people
were sent to the guillotine for speaking
out against the atrocities committed
during the revolution look at the soviet
union
east germany
even the berlin wall was originally
called the anti-fascist wall it wasn't
sold to the citizens of east berlin as a
symbol of oppression designed to keep
them inside a broken communist system it
was sold to them as a protection against
an external threat when big governments
take away rights and liberties they
never tell their citizens that it's to
make their life miserable
they always say it's to protect them or
that it's for their own good and that's
exactly what the liberals are doing as
well creating a phantom bogus threat
that they need to protect us from
and so they're going to give themselves
massive power to regulate the internet
there is no question that the world is
changing rapidly and getting more
dangerous
freedom of expression and freedom of
speech are so important because that's
what gives you the right to argue for
your point of view and when you go back
and look at the course of human history
it's always societies and governments
that stifle free speech where innovation
and human rights are also stifled the
only way we can discover truth is if we
have our ideas tested and debated and
only when our ideas or our beliefs are
put through that rigorous scrutiny and
come out unscathed on the other side can
we be sure that something is true we
must make sure we live in a society
where even if we don't like what's being
said
we protect people's right to say it that
healthy debate of ideas that clash of
perspectives that's what produces better
results now justin trudeau tells us to
just trust him that this isn't about
limiting fundamental rights and
liberties this is just about protecting
you just trust him that he won't abuse
this new power that he's giving his
government this is the same guy who
froze the bank accounts of grassroots
donors who are supporting protests for
freedom this is the same guy who
interfered in a criminal court case and
fired his attorney general when she
wouldn't go along with his corruption
this is the same guy who used the covid
pandemic as an excuse to give a massive
contracts to his friends at the wii
organization and this is the same guy
who has increased funding to his friends
at the cbc sending them more of your tax
dollars and creating a media subsidy
program
now he wants to be trusted with this new
power but the point is it's not even
just about justin trudeau no government
should have the power to control
what you can see and post online that's
why we need to protect free speech
that's why this is important that every
canadian should be very very concerned
about this it's important that you get
engaged on c11 write your member of
parliament let them know that you are
opposed to the government having more
power to control what you can see and
post online social media is all about an
interaction so please leave comments
below while you still can hope you've
enjoyed this video thanks for watching
all right
so
we can take that out i believe there is
a
link here
um
you know what i'll i'll get it after
this video is over and i'll post it in
the description um it's it's a very
simple link you just click it it opens
up and if you live in canada you put you
put in your postal code and then it
pre-fills all this information that you
can send your member of parliament on
why you object to this uh bill c11
so for those of you that are watching
this the 10 year in canada go through
that process you know it's going to take
you 30 seconds you might as well get it
done
now
here's the thing right there they're
talking about
and again when i say they're youtube and
content creators are looking this
looking at this from the angle of well
my ad revenue is going to come down i'm
not going to get the reach that i used
to get we don't really know how this is
going to affect us until the bill passes
and becomes law and that may be another
year could be two years
um there's a long process when it comes
to um
proposing bills and they have critics
that go up against the bills then they
all vote on it then it has to go through
royal assent and then it becomes law and
then there's a time frame between when
it's passed and it actually becomes law
and then they start enforcing the new
rules so again this could take another
one to three years it could take a while
um is it gonna pass i'm gonna say yes um
the reason why i'm saying yes is because
the last time i got involved with
lobbying in a bill
um i think it was 2011
it was about two years of my life that i
spent mostly lobbying bill 55
um
it was a
lobbying group that i hired i must have
spent like 50 or sixty thousand dollars
with the lobbyists so i could go in
rooms and talk to critics and by the way
i see uh who was it that mentioned
jagmeet here so jagmeet singh is the uh
ndp leader he was the critic on the bill
when i was getting involved because he
was an ontario
um bureaucrat at that time he wasn't
federal he was provincial and he was a
guy that i like i sat across from this
guy he's a lying pos
i'm not going to get into all the
details as to why but now he's the
leader of the what's essentially the
socialist party in uh canada and he's
partnered up with justin trudeau and
they have a coalition government now so
um there's really nothing that elected
officials can do that are opposing it if
there's a coalition government that has
enough seats to vote for whatever they
want and push it through
so this is why coalition governments are
i mean that's not what canadians voted
for they voted for essentially
leaders of these different parties and
when they form a coalition then it kind
of goes against
the entire
reason for a democratic voting process
which is kind of pointless at this stage
anyway because people don't vote for
freedom anymore in canada anyway and in
most parts of the world they tend to
vote for free ship which is going to
come at the expense of um your privacy
which is going to come at the expense of
what information you're going to receive
so it's not about canadian
broadcasting um and making sure there's
canadian content broadcasting if that
was the case i could go out and get a
moose and sit on it and broadcast from a
moose and just talk about everything
while making maple syrup pancakes sort
of thing right that's not what it's
going to be about it's
like he was talking about there's always
a story behind the story and as soon as
i heard about the spell i knew exactly
where it was going and exactly what they
were going to do and they're doing the
right thing bringing this to the
attention of people although i don't
know that
um there's anything that
folks can do again because there's a
coalition government um they're going to
pass this bill and it's about
controlling their it's about controlling
information it's about making sure that
nobody speaks out against
uh policies and procedures i.e like what
happened with the truckers in ottawa i.e
like what happened with
uh lockdowns and the excessive amount of
uh
like power that they took and control
that they took away from people's lives
like there's there's people complaining
now incessantly about
backlogs and problems at airports in
canada there was a very popular um video
that was trending on
twitter last week i think um
with somebody that was traveling he was
taking a connecting flight from western
uh canada and he had to stop in toronto
pearson he was going down to the states
and he was just going on and on about
like the delays and the weight lines and
it's just absurd like like people now
have to get to the airport four or five
hours before a flight to make it if it's
an international flight just because of
all the delays and backlogs and you know
you've got to show proof of this and
proof of that and there's also a issue
with lack of staffing too
simply because a lot of people that
didn't want to
put a
experimental substance in their body
either quit or got laid off so
they have hr issues you know as far as
manning what needs to be man for the
extra levels of security and you know
under the guise of protection for us
here and canada is one of the few
countries that's that that still has
that that that absurdity when it comes
to travel it's dumb open up the damn
country let people come and visit let
them spend their you know travel dollars
here let people leave
but you know still we're in a state of
fear because of a purported pandemic so
this is the next thing that's coming
it's you know well when you speak out
against something like that then we have
to control that information you know
it's hilarious because i did that
playing the win podcast
with that doctor that shall not be
mentioned about a week ago which you
know got me locked out of the account
for a week and that was youtube locking
me out because it purportedly violated
uh misinformation i'm not sure how the
guy's a qualified doctor and treats
patients and knows exactly what he's
talking about
but that was them censoring that and now
they're saying well the canadian
government is trying to censor
information so you as creators need to
say something and you as creators you
know need to speak up
it's
it's because something in that bill i
think youtube feels like it's going to
violate their interests and be and be
problematic for them um i haven't read
it yet i don't really have any interest
in reading it because it's just one of
those things it's like what are you
going to do rich why don't you lobby
against this why don't you fight it sort
of thing and i'll tell you what the
solution is in a minute
um what's leon saying here hey rich it's
refreshing to hear your content in
comparison to the other red pill content
it's been uh sorry that
has the risk of over complicating the
core message is all that matters
simplicity is a message i needed and all
the best from holland yeah that's that's
what i try to deliver guys you know
there's a lot of um a lot of bs out
there and fluff but
that's just me um keep it simple man you
know the
oakland's razor you know the the the
simplest uh solution is often the one
that you want to go for you know the
most straightforward the simplest
solution is what you want to go for
so
i'll tell you what we did when it came
to bill 55 when it came to the
provincial parliament um
spent
better part of two years and [ __ ] loads
of money trying to fight it they passed
it anyway uh the bill critics including
jack meets in that they were going to
oppose it and vote against it it still
got passed um and
and it became law um
generally speaking
you know there's people that have
problems for every solution and there's
me that just finds you know solutions to
problems that's just how i operate i've
just gotten good at it i'm not too
worried about this is it going to affect
things when it passes yeah probably is
there going to be something in the
legislation um that's going to offer a
carve out perhaps
but there's other solutions to take like
people say oh rich why don't you just
leave canada and i'm gonna say it again
i spent about two years fighting for
shared custody i'm here i have a kid i
have a kid to raise that is my priority
the only
thing that's a problem here now is like
okay well what if they
like what if it lowers your ad revenue
like to me it's like ad revenue okay
it's a part of the business ads run on
my videos that's fine if that drops or
drops down to zero that would suck it's
not the end of the day though um i'll
still be fine right um the problem is i
think if it boils down to reach at the
end of the day where you can't reach
people that want to watch like if
they're not gonna let youtube run ads
because it's not canadian content i'm
not sitting on my um moose you know
while i'm broadcasting while making
maple syrup pancakes and then they ding
you that's not that big of a deal but if
the reach gets pulled back as well that
could be problematic so we don't know
how this is going to unfold we do know
that they don't listen to constituents
and they don't generally listen to
people that lobby against bills and as
we saw that whoever that dude was that
was the canadian guy talking to
parliament about the bill itself and why
it would be problematic for canadian
content creators it's not something they
care about
all they care about is control and they
care about the you know the control of
the narrative and then they're going to
paint it under the guise of well this is
good for canadian and canadian content
and you know we have to make sure that
we maintain canadian but
how are we canadian anymore when
trudeau's best buddy is klaus schwab
from the world economic forum and he's
hanging out with all these like elitists
and globalists from around the world um
where their agenda is exactly the same
right it's control take away power you
know you get the idea um
you know
some people say it's a psyop
and you know there's parts of that where
it's like maybe it is maybe it isn't i
don't know let me just go to the
chat here for a second and see what else
we got
how does he get voted out um he is the
prime minister i think until 2024 2025
is the next election he called an early
election during the pandemic
strategically uh to extend his term
which she successfully did again if if
if canadians didn't want this they
wouldn't vote for it but they love this
guy the vast majority of canadians keep
voting for this [ __ ] and
you know lock me down harder daddy you
know steal my privacy and my information
harder daddy you know take away more of
my freedoms daddy sort of thing and it's
like
that's what they go for hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you